joining us now Ambassador John Bolton
bastard thanks for being here it's glad
to be with you understand you have a
book out
indeed I want to talk to you a little
bit about the process first some of the
pushback and then I want to get to the
substance obviously I've seen the
interviews you've you've given I have
read the book in jail it is very
detailed 500 pages of your time inside
the room as you say in the room where it
happened how did you write this book I
saw in an interview that you said that
the notes you took lots of notes the
notes as I said in my exit interview
from the White House were destroyed
during the course of my tenure there so
how do you go back and fill in all of
these blanks with that detail these
quotes 500 pages well this is the best
recollection I can put together and
blessed with a pretty good memory and I
thought about how to do this I wrote a
book when I left the George W Bush
administration called surrenders not an
option went through much the same
process when were the notes destroyed
during the course of the usually the
weekend following when they were taken
throughout the thing put in burn bags
that sort of thing but no notes were
taken with me after I left the White
House the White House says they didn't
destroy it so Hugh destroyed that's
correct sure if you destroyed them it
would be a violation of the presidential
Records Act no no during during the
course of the work this was this was
something we were we had burn bags in
our offices and put I don't know how
many documents into the burn bags once
you destroy them is that a problem
legally for you because you destroy the
records that they're supposed to be kept
no I don't think these are records that
are supposed to be kept and and they
were not and many other people followed
the same pattern when did you decide to
write the book well during the course of
being in the administration Ike had gone
in
as a lifelong conservative Republican
hoping that we would have a conservative
Republican administration and it didn't
turn out that way but I guess I should
say also I'm certainly not the first
person in the Trump administration to
write a book Sean Spicer who's written a
book Sara Sanders has written a book
others have written books sure not like
this one this one could be could be seen
as critical as opposed to the others
which were seen as favorable to the
president yes
and obviously it's at the center of
another thing which is the impeachment
I'll get to that in a minute but you
took this job as national security
adviser under the trust of the president
that those conversations were going to
happen inside the White House Fred
flight's your former chief of staff and
national security council said this I
don't believe national security advisers
should be revealing internal candid
discussions with the president the
president has to be able to know that
whatever he says of that in those
discussions won't be made public and if
he thinks they're going to be made
public a president won't consult with
experts and I think that's a very
dangerous prospect for a national
security how do you respond to that well
I don't see it that way at all in fact I
address this precise question in a book
review I wrote in 2014 about Bob Gates's
memoir of his time as Secretary of
Defense in the Bush and Obama
administrations and he published his
memoir during the Obama administration
was criticized for that was criticized
for its potential effect on Hillary
Clinton's presidential run his former
colleague when she was Secretary of
State and I made the point then that
everybody in Washington is an adult in
this process we understand exactly the
way it goes my feeling in basically all
of my government jobs from lower levels
up to the last job was that anything I
said could and quite possibly would be
in the papers this knit the next morning
and this is nothing new in American
history as I point out in Washington's
administration Hamilton and Jefferson
fought with each other
through newspapers funded in part by
putting their writers on government
salaries and
somehow poor George Washington managed
to stumble through it some of those
pictures of you in the back of meetings
adjusting your glasses holding notes
look like in your mind you're arranging
chapters of the book at what time in the
17 months did you say I got to start
really thinking about this and and
without detailed notes were you gonna be
able to do it
I mean you left in September and your
deadline was what the fall well you know
I did something very similar as they say
when I left the Bush administration and
that's the same pattern I followed here
a couple other things on the push back
sarah sanders this morning I said this
John Bolton was your classic case of
someone who was completely drunk on
power who thought he was the president
he was constantly pushing his own agenda
which was all he cared about the big
problem for John Bolton is that's not
how it works he forgot that no one
elected him to anything and that it was
president Trump and president Trump's
agenda that mattered within the White
House well she's just flatly wrong on
that
I think the duty of loyalty that a
senior official owes is to the
Constitution and people of the United
States we're not a feudal society this
is not the Middle Ages we don't own oil
tea to an individual particularly an
individual who routinely undercuts his
own advisers and conversations with
other people
president has talked about almost
everything in this book at one level or
another and often simply not told the
truth so if the deal is the president
gets to say whatever he wants and the
American people don't get to hear the
truth is that the kind of society you
want well on the flip side you have
House Speaker Nancy Pelosi saying you
chose profit over patriotism and here's
what Adam Schiff said about all of this
what John Bolton has demonstrated and I
think to the length and degree that he
indict s-- Donald Trump he also indict
him self for cowardice and for greed
because there were people who did come
forward people like Colonel van Minh and
Fiona Hill who risked their careers and
he lacked that basic courage and
patriotism it was only the greed that
made
come forward in this book so you say
it's about the Constitution and
supporting the American people
Democrats would say why didn't you step
up back then the Democrats have a lot of
reason to be concerned I think because
as I lay out in the book their
impeachment strategy was catastrophic
Alire ong i characterized what they did
is impeachment malpractice they were
driven by their own political objectives
to go after Trump as fast as they could
as narrow as they could because they
were concerned about messing up their
own presidential nomination schedule but
that's almost what they said about
Donald Trump in Ukraine miss using the
power of government for his own
political purposes the reality of
history is and Watergate demonstrates
this beyond debate in in my view the
only way you have a real chance at
impeachment and conviction is through a
bipartisan process if you look at the
Watergate committee Sam Ervin Democrat
chairing at Howard Baker ranking
Republican they didn't start out with
the objective to impeach Richard Nixon
but they uncovered evidence they went
through a lengthy process they had court
fights and they built a growing
consensus in Congress that Nixon had to
go the first senator to call for Nixon
to resign was Jim Buckley conservative
of New York and eventually it was a
group of Republican senators that went
to the White House and said mr.
president you have to resign the
Democrats took exactly the opposite
approach they pushed Republicans into a
partisan corner in the house they
basically accomplished the same thing in
the Senate it's no it's no wonder
they're upset but you say in this book
that they could have impeached on a
number of different fronts they there
were other impeachable offenses you've
read in the book you also told Susan
page with USA Today that if you were a
senator voting you would have voted to
convict but there was more than you
needed to know about Ukraine and it
might not be impeachable don't you feel
some responsibility now that you're
saying he should have been impeached for
on other things but you know
pipe top I'm not saying he should have
been impeached I'm saying there's a lot
of reprehensible conduct not all of
which is impeachable the the fact was
the Democrats were pursuing a strategy
that was clearly going right into a
ditch and they had opportunities to to
try and correct the course they didn't
they never issued me a subpoena this is
this is something that I think a lot of
people don't understand they never
issued me a subpoena and they did to
everybody else who testified I think
it's evidence that they were pursuing a
very partisan course of action that was
their choice I think it was a mistake I
don't have any obligation to help the
Democrats drive into a ditch my thought
was it may not take a village but at
least it takes a book to explain what
actually happened that I saw that I
could attest to personally but you were
gonna fight it you were enjoying a
coverman lawsuit and you were gonna
fight that until the Senate Republicans
you said would have a choice whether to
subpoena you or not your bet was that
Senate Republicans would not and they
didn't know Pepperman went to court to
say to a judge tell me which of these
conflicting orders do I follow it he
wanted the third branch of government to
resolve the conflict between the first
two and the reaction of the House of
Representatives was to withdraw the
subpoena why would you vote to convict
what President Trump did in Ukraine as
far as I could see based on my
observation was to use government power
to further his own political interests
but you said that was enough if you were
a senator you would vote to convict I
thought they didn't have all the
information because you didn't provide
it no I think the the fact was that
there was not going to be broad support
for impeaching the president certainly
among Republicans without looking at a
whole range of conduct the Democrats
veered into the Ukraine almost by
accident they had been focusing on what
I think everybody agrees now is
something the Russia collusion
allegations as to which there was no
basis in fact and so to me a partisan
rush
to use the impeachment mechanism doesn't
require everybody else to make the same
mistake and the most important way that
the American people control their
government and control their president
is through elections and I think a lot
of people said that at the time the
judge who ruled that you could release
this book today also put in there some
stiff language saying that you
threatened national security and that
there are real questions about what is
released here are you confident that
you're not going to face any criminal or
other liability after this I am very
confident that there's no classified
information in the manuscript I never
intended to put classified information
out there I've spent the life
professionally in the government trying
to advance American interest and that's
really continued in the process of the
book the subsequent review I think was
part of a campaign by the President to
suppress the book and what makes it most
revealing let me just read from judge
Lambeth could I just Olin has gambled
with national security of the United
States he has exposed his country to
harm and himself to civil and
potentially criminal liability we
respectfully disagree with what the
judge said there and there'll be a civil
litigation process during which the
story will be told and I'm confident it
will be but what President Trump said
that shows the political nature of the
campaign to suppress the book was that
he said not before the election after
the election okay that show is that the
national security issue doesn't change
just because of the election what does
change is Donald Trump's personal
fortune and I think that's what that's
what this is about about some of the
details here are things that really
raise some eyebrows one of them is about
a meeting a dinner meeting outside the
g20 in Osaka Japan in which you say that
the president talked with President Xi
of China about the election it was
obvious that the president was urging Xi
Jinping to purchase more agricultural
products to help him in states that were
important for his life
and you write in the book that that's
exactly what happened however ambassador
light Heiser
on Capitol Hill under oath was asked
about this very thing this very meeting
is reset absolutely ountry never
happened I was there I've no
recollection of that ever happening I
said what meeting I was at and this
never happened in it for sure
he's under oath on Capitol Hill saying
that right well look we could we could
line all of us who were at that meeting
up under oath I'd be happy to do that
too that is my recollection but I think
more importantly I think that's what the
Chinese side recollects as well did you
tell anybody about that after that
meeting or your concerns about that I
had a number of conversations about it
within the NSC there's buddies like
White House chief of staff make Mulvaney
or White House Counsel or someone like
done I don't know about Mulvaney but I
think there were a lot of conversations
about it as there were about other
issues that I did brief the White House
Counsel and the Attorney General on
there's a certain point I think when
everybody hears these things in the
White House they've become inured to
them and I think that's a real part of
the problem in the Trump administration
it happened so often that it deadens and
sensitivities the other one that you
point out from that g20 meeting in Osaka
the side by lap was this talk about the
Weger of concentration camps the
retraining camps you say that the
president essentially said go ahead and
build them right this was what was
reported both at Osaka and at a previous
conversation between Xi Jinping and the
president by the interpreters who herded
the being said that's what that's what I
was I mean you were sure that that's
what was said that that's what was
because that's I open if true and it's
it's consistent with his approach to
human rights in China generally even
though for example he recently signed
congressional legislation which which
really simply consolidated sanctions
authority he already had
not not just a few days ago he said that
the Weger issue had interrupted his
trade negotiations with China
the point is not what he believes when
he signs the particular legislation or
what he says when he's dealing with the
Chinese it's that he doesn't
particularly believe any of it longer
than it takes to get past the day he's
dealing with it did you brief the
President on the Weger issue prior to
that meeting we've had conversations
about the Uighur there were interagency
meetings going on within the National
Security Council about the kinds of
sanctions we should impose on China did
you advise them to condemn the camps
what was working up what would have been
a series of sanctions that the president
already had authority to impose on the
weavers and it was at the White House
Christmas dinner in 2018 for the senior
staff and their spouses the president
said to me had said to Wilbur Ross
earlier in the week and said to me at
that dinner I want this stop so you
advise him to condemn the camps and he
just reversed that at that meeting well
in effect that stopped the process of
deciding what sanctions to recommend
doing and it was consistent with the way
he treated the repression of Hong Kong
citizens by the government in Beijing
his unwillingness to issue a White House
statement on the anniversary of
Tiananmen Square the 30th anniversary he
heard that the State Department had
issued a statement and he told Mike
Pompeo wish you hadn't done that this is
this is the sort of approach that he
that he has taken in a variety of
context dealing with those kinds of
issues you cite secretary Pompeo in the
book as somebody that you talk to a lot
seemed to see your point of view on
things
secretary Pompeo has called you a
traitor he openly saralyn celebrated
when you left the White House yet you
say that he shared North Korea views
Rahn China so how do you think Pompeo is
so trusted in this White House for so
long well I think he took the view that
that I think led to disagreements
between us that even in issues where he
thought the president was moving in the
wrong direction he would just stop
trying to persuade him stop trying to
fix what was clearly a problem and I
think his political future is very much
tied to the Trump administration and I
can understand what he's doing any
reaction to the trader talk he compared
you to the Edward Snowden yeah that's
complete nonsense but on the other hand
the president was quoted months ago as
calling me a traitor so the fact that
Mike Pompeo does is par for his course
the South Koreans have weighed in saying
this book does not reflect accurate
facts and substantially distorts facts
unilaterally publishing consultations
made on a mutual trust violates the
basic principles of diplomacy and can
could severely damage future
negotiations there's not a lot of people
happy about this book look if you don't
write the truth about these things at a
point where the voters in South Korea or
the voters in the United States can act
on it I think you're doing a disservice
to the people you did many interviews
after the summit and Singapore where you
said that it was a success and that
American interests were protected you
were pressed again on Face the Nation
I'm the national security adviser I'm
not the national security
maker but you write in the book that you
were mad you were upset that you did not
take your advice on North Korea on Iran
on China but you weren't the
decision-maker
that's correct and ultimately that's why
I resigned the the point is that at
least I can speak for myself but I think
for many others who have also resigned
or left the White House of the
administration you work as hard as you
can to provide the advice it's best that
just comes a point where your political
capital has been expended where it's
clear the president is not inclined to
listen and was that point the failure to
launch an attack against Iran after the
drone strike
no that wasn't that wasn't the point
although I thought about it then I
thought about it a lot of times I had a
letter of resignation written for quite
some time in advance what the final
straw was although it was really the
accumulation of events was the
president's idea of inviting the Taliban
to Camp David to sign the so-called
Afghan peace agreement which I thought
was a bad agreement I thought the
president was pursuing the wrong policy
and I thought that the decision to bring
them to Camp David was was just I just
couldn't respond to it you went in with
a long history in foreign policy as
being someone who was hawkish on a lot
of issues this president was never that
way and going in could you see the
disparity between where you were
historically on foreign policy and where
this president was campaigning well you
know I think I try and establish in the
first chapter of the book how I got the
job and I talk about a series of
meetings that I had with the president
where he didn't focus on the differences
between certainly Iraq was a difference
that was clear from the beginning but as
I said to and he and I did agree that
Obama had made a big mistake in 2011 in
pulling all American troops out I have
never been criticized for being shy
about giving people my opinions I said
on Fox and and in plenty of speeches and
in 500 bad articles between the time I
left the Bush administration the time I
joined the Trump administration so the
idea that somehow he was blindsided by
what I believe is just not credibly
speaking not credible that is what
George W Bush said about you did not
believe that you were credible a :
Powell
obviously had a lot of things to say
about you other administrations and
other people you've worked with have
painted a negative picture is there
somebody that you've worked with that
has a positive perspective on your time
well I hope there are a lot of people
have a positive perspective I've been
criticized for a lot of things there's a
long list of that I'm sure
but I've always tried to say what I
thought to that point you say that the
president was really transactional he
didn't have an ideology at driving
principle you say that that was a real
problem that there was no principle in
his foreign policy supporters would say
America first is a principle and not
going into endless wars and his words is
a principle you said at the Heritage
Foundation in December of 2018 I think
the president's transactional history of
making deals that are mutually
beneficial because you don't make many
successful investments unless the people
on the other side of the transaction get
something out of it true is is something
that should encourage
African governments that's not what you
write in this book well the idea of
making successful deals is something
that any president diplomatically wants
to try and do the record here has been
pretty inadequate in terms of those
deals despite the president's assertion
that that's what he does better than
anybody else been speaking as a lifelong
conservative Republican I wrote this
book for everybody liberal conservative
moderate
but for conservatives especially I think
it's important to see what they've
actually got there and it's not a
conservative philosophy it's not a
liberal philosophy either it's no
philosophy at all and so in a second
term I think conservatives should think
about the implications of what that
means